はい よろしくお願いします
あのまあ 今日のテーマは
この雰囲気という テーマなんです
説明は あの もうお聞きになられたと思いますけど
私たちにとっては結構大事なポイントだとは思います
で この雰囲気っていうのは
人間というものは あの
面白いもので 生命は誰でも同じなんですけど
まあいつでも常にある
なんとかある特定の波動を出しているんですよ
自分から出しているだけではなくて
また受けていることもするんですね
だから我々は ある常に何かの波動を送信したり受信したりしているんです
で これが私はプラスマイナスと書いたんですけど
いわゆるネガティブとポジティブということで
受ける受信する波動が時々自分が受け入れたくない嫌なものの場合もあるし
自分の心から体から送信する波動も
周りの環境によって受け受け入れたくない
すごい嫌なことになる場合もありますし
逆もありますね 自分が受信する波動が大変心地よいもので
あるいは自分が発信する波動も
他人に対して 環境に対してすごい心地よいものふうにはなります
ですから まあ大雑把には 2つ類には分けられますけどね
そこで この我々は本当にそんなに電波塔ですか？と
それで まあ人間だけではなくて
全ての生命は一応電波塔なんです
で 心を持ってるんだから
心っていうのは この科学でわかるものじゃないんですね
頭で考えてわかるものでもないんです
それはもう  科学の世界で研究していないんだからね
で いくら仏教を教えてあげても聞く耳は持てないし
ですから これはもうわからないということにした方がいいんじゃないかなと
誰かヨーロッパのね 頭混乱している人が説明しない限りはもう聞かないんだから
とにかくあの 我々の体といっても
この物質 そういうものを支配して維持管理しているのは心なんだから
心というのはすごいエネルギーなんです
それでずっとこの送信したり受信したり
それはこのまあ 止まりません
永久に  例えば人が麻酔状態にいるとしますね
で 何も考えてないでしょうね
それでも我々はその人は生きてると知ってるんです
何のことなく知ってはまだ生きているんだと
まあたまたま心臓が止まったり
息が止まったりする時もあります
その時は放っておけば死にますけど
やっぱりその時医者がいればね
ちゃんと頑張るんですよ
生き返してもらおうと思って
で 頑張っているんだけど
ある時点でやめるんですね
もうダメだと 医者はいまだに知らない
そのどんな時それやめるのかと
ただ 自分たちがすごいことを勉強しているんだから
心臓停止とか まあ呼吸停止とか呼吸困難とか
なんとかで死にましたと言うんですけど
心臓停止はもっとも先に起きてあったんですよ
なのに 電気を与えたり
もうマッサージしたり
いろんな 苦労するんです
生き返してもらおうということで
だから この科学で説明するところと違うところがあるんです
それで心臓マッサージとかね
心臓に電気ショックを与えることは
いっそやめるかと 医者に聞いてもわからないんですが
見事にやめるんですよ
まあやっぱりもうダメやと
やっぱりそのダメやとやめる瞬間にもう体は物体になってしまって
もう命のひとかけらもないんです
すぐ見たらわかるんですよ
これはなんでわかるのかと
誰もわからないんです
生きてるっていうことだけはわかる
なんでわかるのかと だから医学的には心臓なんぞやとかね
血液は流れているんだと
あれやこれやというだけの話で
でも血液の流れが止まっても
まだ生きているという感じはあるんですよ
それがまあ 心は最後にその体から電波を出すということをやめたんでいいんですよ
電波を出すということは
全部まあ停止したら まあそれでお手上げ
それから何もすることができん
だから たとえ心臓が止まってあっても
呼吸が止まってあっても
まだ心が発信しているんです
微妙かもしれませんだけど
発信しているんですけど
それは周りの人々はものすごく感じるんです
だから 意識とは考えることとか全然関係ないんです
どうしてもそこは説明できん
だから感じるしかないんですよ
ただ生きているということは感じる
それは客観的に直接に感じるものだから
理屈はいらん それがこのもう発信する送信する機能なんですね
そこは止まりません だからこの体が止まったところで
あ 死んだ もうまあそれで終わりと
もう人はもうこの今世しかないんだぞとかいうのは
もうあまりにもものをわからないということは
世間にちょっと大げさに言ってるだけで
わからないってことはコソコソで言った方がいいのにね
なんでそんなに大げさにするんでしょうかと
だからこれ私はもう最近使っている単語なんですけど
もう馬鹿自慢しているんだと
もうこんなに威張って馬鹿自慢しなくてもいいんですけど
だからそもそも心のことわかってないんだから
この現に目の前でもうジリジリとあるのに
だから そのエネルギーの働きがわかる人にとっては
もうこれは止まるもんじゃないとわかるんですよ
だから人が死んでからまた人間に生まれ変わることは
それは全然想像できんよと言ってもできるわけないでしょうに
我々はそんなことを言っているわけでもないし
時々仏教で言ってるんだから
人が死んじゃったら地獄に落ちるかもしれませんし
動物として生まれ変わる可能性もあるんだよと
そんなのは信じられませんと
ああ そうということで終わっちゃいますよ
別に信じてほしくないしね
大きな噂ですけど そんな馬鹿に信じてもらったってもね
そんなこのすごい大変な次元の違う難しい話なんです
一般の人にわかる ないんです
だから仏教というのは人が死んで犬に生まれ変わったとかね
そういうふうな話じゃなくて
心のエネルギーは止まることなく回転していく
だから死んですぐどうなるのかっていうことは
この悟った阿羅漢たち
それもその能力ある人以外はわからないんだと
そこで私たちは死ぬ瞬間に
次に何どんな波動に変わるのかということ
我々には全くできないんです
管理 だから凡夫でいること
悟らないでいることほど危険なことはないんだと
この電波とかもう瞬時に変わって
どんな波動出すかわからないんです
だから死ぬ瞬間でも発信しているんですよ
そこまた受信する場所もあるんです
だから自分の発信している波長に合わせてるところ
チャネルを合わせるところで受信しちゃうんですよ
そこで生まれちゃうんです
だから知ったものじゃないんで
こちらではね  そこで この我々は常に絶えず出しているこの波動が
どこから出てくるのかで
そんなに難しくないんです
常に我々はもうなんとかすごいエネルギーを持ってるんですね
生きているっていうエネルギーが
その中で一番タチが悪いのはこの感情というものなんですね
思考とかではないんです
感情絡むとかなりタチが悪いんです
勉強するものなんかは随分簡単に忘れるでしょう
しかし 感情絡むと絶対忘れませんね
例えば私の話しの内容っていうのは
もうたった時点で忘れると思いますけど
もし私の話を聞いてちょっと腹が立ったりしたら
これは年経っても忘れません
あいつは嫌やと 私もなんでそんなにもう嫌なことばっかし羅列するのかというと
怒ることっていうのは随分簡単ですからね
慣れてますから みんな
笑うよりは だからそれと常時になんとかして真理を私は伝わっているんです
だから苦ければ食べないと
臭くなければ食べないという性格だから
それはもう私にはどうすることもできないんです
ですから できるだけ辛口でしか言えないんです
すごく優しく言っちゃうと
やってみたんですよ もう６０パーセントの方々は寝ているんです
むちゃくちゃもう批判しながら
もう貶しながら言うと
もうやっぱり起きて聞いてるんです
それで大量に怒りを持ち運びますけど
やっぱり怒りだけはいかないんですよ
その中に何とか中身を入れているんです
そうやっても騙して教えることしかできなくなっている状態なんです
騙されて教え理解するとか
あまりいいこと かっこいいことじゃないんですよ
ちゃんと自分の意思で
もう知らないことは知ってやるんではないかというね
まあ明るい波動を出してもらえば
もうそれに合わせますけどね
はい まあそれは余計な話で
我々には怒りとか欲とかね
嫉妬とか憎しみとかね
恨みとか で いろんな感情があるんですね
その感情自体がすごくタチが悪くて
そう簡単には消えません
で 私たちはその感情をどんどんどんどんどんどん
繰り返し繰り返し死なないことにしているんです
消すことはできますよ
だから この心が絶えず回転することは
我々は自分の意思で勝手にやっているんです
だから涅槃というのは可能なんです
自分でやめればいいんだから
続くのも自分勝手でしょうに
だからもう自分勝手でやめればいいんです
例えば怒ったら もうもう８０年経っても
その怒りだけは覚えている
覚えているはずがないんですよ
すぐ忘れるはずなんです
なんで忘れないのかというと
繰り返し繰り返し思い出して
思い出して この怒りをリピートするんです
で 我々はそうやって この怒り
憎しみなどをね 嫉妬とかね
落ち込みとか そういう嫌な人をもう破壊する
ダメになる不幸にする感情はすごくありがたく
大事に あの すごく可愛がって育てるんです
だから人間と人間にもそれが悪いというと
もう人間関係も作れないんですよ
だから我々はだいたいそういう性格で
この感情によってこの電波が出てくるんです
だからそれ何やと言って言えないんだから
このまあ 雰囲気という言葉を使っています
それで 知識 理性 情報 知恵
思考などの送受信はできません
悪いことに 例えば私の知識を送信するということはできないんです
怒りだったらできますよ
もし私がすごく喜んでいるんだったら
その喜びを送信できます
しかし 知識の送信できません
理性の送信もできません
情報の送信もできません
例えば 私は今日何食べたかと
顔を見てわかる？わからないでしょうに
それ情報でしょ でも私は気分がいいか悪いかわかるでしょう
見ただけで で あるいは感情は何なのかと
怒っているかないかとかね
それぐらいはすぐわかる
それまでわかっているんだったら
心の隅までわかっているんだったら
なんで今日は何食べたかとかわからないんですかね
もっと単純でしょうに
それが情報ですよ 受信できないし
送信もできないんです
それで理解できると思います
私は何言おうとしているのかと
だから知識なんかは自分で頑張って勉強しないと心に入るものじゃないんです
理性というものも あらゆる話を聞いて聞いて
聞いて聞いて 自己改革しない限りは
理性っていうものはもう生まれてこないんです
だからそれが自分が頑張って育てないと
そうまあ 悪ではなくてでいけないんですね
とにかく 送受信するのは雰囲気と言えるもので
だからこれ 雰囲気と雰囲気という言葉というのはすごい大雑把な
あの俗世間の言葉なんですけど
その言葉でしかもう言えないんですよ
各人は自分の雰囲気を持ってるんです
それで すべての生命も自分の雰囲気を持ってるんです
だから犬も猫も自分の雰囲気というのを持っているんです
これを我々は送受信するんです
だから犬に好かれる人もいて
嫌われる人もいるでしょうに
こちらから見れば あの犬は好きなんです
そちらからは嫌やとお前のことはとあるでしょうに
だから全部生命がそこを送受信しているんです
皆様と現代人というのは頭がいいんだから
この地球上の人間と動物以外生命がないと断言していますけど
どうやって証明したかどうかわかりませんだけど
これは送受信の問題で
それ以外のものは送受信できないんですよ
もし我々は私たちの受信の
をね さらに幅広く波長広く受信できるようにしておけば
何のことなく他の生命の存在っていうのはわかるんです
だから仏典なんか見てみると
日常茶飯事のことで なんとかなんとか神が来て
なんとかなんとか質問したとか
お釈迦様はなんとかなんとかの名前の梵天とも話し合っていたんだとかね
そういうのは仏教の世界ではもう何のことなく当たり前のこと
別にという感じで聞いているんです
そこは仏教でない人々も読んでみれば
やっぱりこれがあるとまずいとかね
もう中身は一応論理的にわかりますけど
これは神がこんなこと来てじゃ
こんなの認めませんと
というようなことを言うんですね
だから私たちにとっては
じゃあどうぞ勝手にしてくださいということしかもう態度取れないんですよ
どうやってその人にそれを説得できますかね
だから もし私たちの私たちも電波等でしょうに
我々は狭い幅の電波しか受けてないだけの話で
だから心の受信機能をより幅広くすれば
他の生命の存在は知ります
しかし あの 何といいますか
あれは なんとか単語がありますけど
時々いますね 他の生命とコンタクトを取るという
チャネリングとかね チャネラーとかね
まあ言葉正しいんですよ
言葉は正しいんで チャネリングするという
しかし あの情報の電波で送信できないんですよ
たとえ受信しても そちらの雰囲気だけ受信するんですよ
だから誰か誰かこういうことを言いました
死んだあなたのおじいさんがこんなこと言いました
あんなのは全部嘘インチキ
だって いくら調べたっても
誰でも知ってるごく当たり前のことしか言わんでしょうね
もし違う次元にいるならば
我々のもうなんとかって
我々は繰り返すほどのことを言うはずんですよ
でも言わない 餓鬼道のうちで苦しんでいたっても
じゃあ君のことをよく守っているとかね
見守っているとかね これはどんな人間も思っていることだから
死んだおじいさんが見守っているんだと
生きていることは何の役にも立たなかったんだけどというね
死んだら千智千能でもよく守ってくれると
それは一般の人々の考え方で
これチャネラーがそれ言うんですね
だからまあチャネリング機能
私は否定しませんよ 言葉も正しいんで合ってます
しかし 受信できるのはあの雰囲気なんです
こう言ったああ言ったということはできない
だからこのいろいろ神様が現れてなんとか予言しましたとかあるでしょう
もう最近まで結構ありましたからね
しかし 神様のに予言当たらないでしょうに
なんででしょうかね あれ
オーストラリアかな なんかマリア様が現れるんだということで
大勢の人が行ってね それでもなんとか日にちちゃんと行って
この日にちではなんとかするんだと
みんな怯えていたんです
それからもう世界は滅びるんだと
その日にちはもうたくさん人々を集めて
テレビ取材やら待っていたんですけど
全然現れなかったんです
それでこのチャネラーが神様は延期しましたと
日にちは後で報告するんだと
自分にそう言ったんだということで
みんな見事に信仰をさらに固めて帰りました
まあまあ そんな程度ですから
人間の理解っていうのは
どう見たっても人間にでも
でもね 明日行きますよって言ってあると
時を起こしてこたえられない限りは行くでしょうに
約束したんだから でないとみっともないと思うでしょうに
この感情の掃除機 感情の掃除機もできますけど
この本当はこの怒り憎しみってよりも微妙なものをなんかわからないものでしょう
出しているのは だから我々は雰囲気という言葉を使っているんです
一般的には まあ本当はそれの怒り憎しみなんですが
怒り憎しみと私たち言うほどのものじゃないんです
なんかちょっと気分が悪いみたいというふうに思うだけ
あの人なんか今日はちょっと気分が悪いみたい
言っても その人はもしかすると怒り出しているかもしれません
憎しみ出しているかもしれません
嫉妬を出しているかもしれません
落ち込みを出しているかもしれません
悔しさを出しているか
どちら 全部まとめたって怒りですけど
だからあまり感情はわからない
なんで今日はあなたは気分が悪いですかと
我々は情報を取らなくちゃいけないんです
それで情報を取ってみたところで
あっ この人は怒っている
この人は落ち込んでいると
それでやがてわかるんです
しかし 我々に情報取る前にすぐ怒っているんだということを表現することはできます
言わないでも ただいただけで
この人は怒りの塊や この人は欲の塊だ
この人は無知の塊だということを言える時もあります
その場合はあまりにも明確だから
そんなに難しいことではありません
はい そこで受信だけする人間
人間というのは送受信だから両方やっています
あの 完全に受信だけするっていうのは
もう本当はありえないんです
ありえないんですけど
もう 1億ぐらい受信して
もう 2つぐらい送信したっても
まあ一応ゼロに等しいんだからね
そんな気にしなくてもいいんです
受信だけするのは 精神的に極端に弱い人
生きてるか死んでるかさっぱりわからない
人間見るでしょうに 時々我々も怒って
あんた本当に生きてるんですかと聞いたりもする時あるでしょうに
受信だけするというね
だから生きてはいるんだよ
受信しているんだから
でも生き物だったら送信もしないと
そういうことですごい極端に弱い人っていうのは
ほとんど受信するばっかしに期待しているんです
自分が生き続けるために
それから精神的に正常でない人
で いろいろ妄想して で
ちょっと音が聞いただけで
あの人私の悪口言ってるんだとかね
あの人嫌なことやってるんだとかね
私はわかってますよと
例えばそういう病気の人だったら
もう一緒に家にいる誰かがドアを閉じたとする
普通のことをドア閉じたら音が出る
あれ 嫌がらせやってるんだと
わざと あんたどうやってわかるの？私はわかりますよと
それで そういう精神的に病気な人々を扱っているというとも
ものすごい感動 感情が鋭くてすごい鋭いんだと
そんなことまで言うんです
逆なんですけど で 頭がいいんだとかね
ただ受身するだけで これが病気なんです
それから極端な依存症というね
あらゆる依存症がありますよ
アルコール依存症にしたっても
受身型の人間なんです
だから何かに引っかかって受身する
だから依存症になるんです
それから怯え 不安 恐怖などに抑えられた人
それはもう私たちにも時々あります
私たちも時々突然受身だけする人間になってしまう時はあります
強烈な怯えとか強烈な不安とかね
襲ってきたらもう何もできなくなっちゃうでしょ
硬直するでしょうに だから他人が来て
もの徹底的に助けてあげないと
怯えて震えて もうもうあっち走ったりこっち走ったり
手も足も何にも出ない状態で
言葉も喋れなくなっちゃうんです
硬直しちゃうんです だから時々我々にもなんかそういうふうなことが起きちゃうと
もう精神的な病気の人と同じことをやるんです
その時も我々は受身だけする
まあ例えばもう地震が起きたりとかね
何か大変なことが起きたりしちゃうと
ずっと訓練を受けているのに
その時に限って変なことをするんでしょう
あのレスキュー隊が行っても徹底的に助けてあげないと
レスキュー隊も大変危険なことをやっているんだから
こちら側もそれなりにすればいいでしょうに
例えば洪水でもうバスの上でもいいんだけど
もう避難していると どんどん水が上がってくる
バスの上まで上がるかもしれません
予測しなかった怯えでしょうに
で その時はヘリが来てロープを下ろしてくれればそれだけで十分なんですけど
それをきちんと自分の腰に巻いてあげ
巻いて はい  OK と言えば
向こうはもう機械で引っ張るだけなんですけど
これできないんですよ
その人には そこでヘリから人がまた降りて
あの危険な状態で一人一人もうちゃんとつなげて
安全大丈夫 大丈夫 もう壊れませんよと
このロープはとかね すごい苦労しなくちゃいけないんです
だからレスキュー隊の命もすごい危うく状態になるんです
だからそれにいくら悪口言ったって意味がないんですよ
そういう人々は正常な時はそんなのは知ってるんです
興奮してはあかんと混乱して開けないといけませんとかね
地震が起こるとすぐ火なんか消すもんだよとかね
窓なんか開けておくもんだよとかね
ドアったら開けておくんだよと偉そうなこと言うんですけど
実際地震が起きると何もしないんです
その時 我々の心理状態どうなるのかというと
予測もできない もう対応できない強烈な恐怖感に襲われているんですね
そこで受身するだけになっちゃう
だから半分死んでるんです
で それから無知だけがある人もいるんですけどね
何も自分で行動しない
仏教でいう地獄っていうのは大体そんなような次元なんです
自分の意思で何もやらない
それで極端に苦しむんだそうです
はい 次に行きます それから反対に送信だけする人
それ反対ですよ 精神的に極端に強い人にのみできる
送信だけする 相手に影響を与えるだけすることは
もうすごい強烈な もう精神的に極端に強い人でしかできないんです
要するに 悟りを開いた人の能力です
普通の人にはできない
他に影響を与える 他の人々の心も性格も何でも変えてみせる
しかし 向こう側から何か受身しようとはしない
例えば お釈迦様は人々から何一つも期待しないで
説法したんです 現代の世界でも
神様たち 仏様たち ブッダたちっていっぱいいますけど
みんな与えるものよりも何倍も期待しているんです
信者さんから やっぱり普通の人間なんですね
送受信両方やっているんです
褒めてくれないと腹が立つんです
おだててもらわないと気分が悪いとかね
時々殺される 神様や私は仏やと言い張ってますけど
まあちょっと批判したらもうやられちゃいます
それぐらい受信に期待しているんです
だから悟っているわけじゃない
どう見ても普通の人間なんです
神でもないんです 神っていうのは理想って観念的で言えば全知全能で受信するはずがないんです
受信する必要はないんです
だって全知全能だから
しかし 私は神様と言い張っている人々は
もうほとんど受信だけに期待しているんです
神らしいものは一つもやらないんです
だから たとえ神様が来て
私はあなた方にこういうことを期待しているんだぞと言ったら
この神の資格がなくなっちゃうんです
だって何か受信しようとしているんだから
だから完全慈悲でなければいけません
何も期待していないんだと
でも あんた方は無知でアホで苦しんでいるのは良くないんだから
ただ言ってるだけですと
やりたければやりなさいという態度でないと完全じゃないんです
なぜ仏教はそんな態度で語っているのかというと
ブッダが悟ったんだからなんです
お釈迦さんはあんたが修行したってもしなくても知ったもんか
そんなの しかし教えてあげると
間違ったら直してあげる
と ちょっとやる気が失ったら
もうとことん尻を叩いてもう励ましてあげる
と やるかやらないか自分で勝手ですと
なぜかというと 人が修行して悟ったっても
お釈迦様はその受信も何もしない
何のお釈迦様にとってはいりません
だからあるバラモンが
あなたももう私と同じ
もう見事な仕事をしているでしょう
ですから このご飯食べてくださいといりませんと断ったんです
そのバラモンは 托鉢に行ったお釈迦様には
私は仕事をしてご飯を食べている
あんたはね ただ鉢を持ってくるだけで
あんた方も仕事をしたらどうですか？と言うと
お釈迦様は私たちもしっかり仕事をしているんだと言って説法したんです
彼が農業だ 畑 田んぼをやって
だからアハンコウサマナカサミチワパミチ
カシットワチワピットワチブンジャミ
シャモン 私はもう畑を作って田んぼを作って食べてますよと
トワンプリサマナカサッスチワパスと
カシットワチワピットワチブンジャス
あなたも田んぼなんか作って食べたらどうですか？それでお釈迦様はアハンピコブラフマナカサミチワパミチ
同じ言葉で言うんです
私も土をいじって水を入れて田んぼを作って食べてるんだよ
と言ったら この修行者が何言うんでしょうかと
牛はあるわけじゃないし
土地は持ってるわけじゃないし
あの sweets 何て言いますか
種 種なんか持ってるわけじゃないでしょ
それで私には牛も見えませんし
土地も見えませんと 田んぼも見えません
種も見えませんと それからツキも見えませんよと
なのにあなたは田んぼを耕していると言ってではないか
というと お釈迦様はちゃんと説法したんです
サッダビジャンタポウッティ
で サッダシンという種であると
修行は雨で降ってくる雨であると
パンニャーメユガナンガラン
知恵というのは 私はもう土を耕す牛であると
あ ヴィリヤン それから精進
サティメターラパーチャナン
で 牛をもう脅して脅して動いてもらわないとね
もう好きが動かないんだから
それは私はサティでやってますよと
そういう風に説法したら
それで私はアマタ 無私なる涅槃というものを刈り取って味わっているんだと
永遠な命を味わっているんだと言うと
見事ですね ブラマン人に答えは
ブラマン人こそ喜んで
さすがあなたは仕事をしている
では このご飯召し上がってください
それは要りませんと 私はこの歌って歌っていくらかちょうだいという人じゃないんだよと
だから期待しない あのボラモンがただ托鉢した人に何も期待しないで施したならば
その人に徳になる 説法したんだから
この代わりとして なんとなく何ではないんだけどとかなんと言っても
それは受け取れません
ですから この微妙に人には期待しなかったんです
微妙なところでも しかし
人類に悟りの道を教えたんです
休むことなく だからこの悟った人だけなんですね
送信塔になっているのは
それまでは素晴らしい波動だけ送信しているんです
人々に 人々が幸福になる
すごい強烈なんです えーと
他の宗教の指導者たちも強力な影響力を持っているが
送信するだけの人間ではないようです
例えば宗教家っていうのはかなり送信者なんですよ
例えば イエス様の影響っていうのはもうかなりいまだに受けているでしょうに
かなり送信してしたんです
他の宗教の方々もそれなりに送信はしている
だからみんな受信してその人につなげているんです
しかし ブッダみたいに完全に送信のみということじゃないんです
他人に頼っちゃうんです
いろんな面で 例えば イエス様がどうかお祈りするために行って
もうもう自分が殺される
まあほんのちょっと前なんですけど
本人もすごい精神的な不安定で
もう死にたくはなかったということははっきりしているし
で 一人で真夜中出て行ってお祈りしたんですけど
その間で素晴らしい弟子たちはだらしなく寝ているんですね
で 帰ったらもうもうイエス様怒ったんですけど
なんであなた方は起きていないのかと
やっぱり期待があるんですよ
自分を愛して自分を大事にして
まあ当てにならないことは知ってますよ
その人々にそんな力はなかったし
で やられるっていうことは知っていたんですけども
最低まあ自分が拾ったあのろくでもない 12人がね
本当に面白いんですよ
もうなんとももうことできない人ばっかり選んじゃったんだからね
まあ最低自分の先生でしょうに
まあちょっと快く待っていれば心配すればいいのに
やらなかったんです お釈迦様も同じ
大体仏教からほとんどコピーした可能性ありますよ
お釈迦様もそういう風にもうもう寝ていた時は怒鳴った時あるんです
真夜中なんです よくも寝ているんだと
それは私が寝ていないんだから
君たちは私のために待っていなさいって意味じゃないんです
常に燃えているのに いつ死ぬかわからないのに
あんた方に寝る暇もありますかと
だから一瞬でも惜しんで修行して悟りなさいよという話なんです
お釈迦様 自分のために言ったわけじゃないんです
だらしないな 何やってるんですか？と
よく寝る暇があるんだと
瞬間瞬間も死にいたっているのにという叱りなんです
だから ただ単に一方的に相手を怒鳴るだけ
それで起きていて 修行して悟ったんだからといって
お釈迦様には別にどうということは何ともないんです
で 他の他人の影響によって動揺しない不動の心の持ち主
これいいっていうことはないんですけど
もう悟った人は人の話にはまるっきり動揺しないんですから
悟りそのものも何にも揺らぎない心を作ることだからね
それとはこれは これはもう一方的に頑固というかね
あるいは無知というか
どちらかなんです それでも私たちも他人に言われることに動揺しない分はしっかりはするんです
で その時は自分で送信する
それで相手が受信して
それに合わせて行動する
だから自分が送信したんだから
自分の期待通りにみんな動くことになるんです
で ヤクザみたいなもんですけど
まあものすごい凶暴で
言いたいことばっかり一方的に言う
向こうは受信側で受信するだけ
そうすると受信したら反応しなくちゃいけないんだから
その言った人の希望通りに反応する
ということになります
はい 次に行きます 総合的に送信受信する人間
先日の両者を除き 全ての人々ですね
我々はだいたい送受信両方やっています
送受信続くことで 自分自身の生きる不安
生きる苦しみを和らげるのです
なんで生命は絶えず送受信しているんでしょうかと
あ それで我々は生きていることっていうのはものすごい不満なんですよ
不安なんです 瞬時に死んじゃうんです
それで頭が悪いことはありがたいんですけど
本当は明確に見ると この我々の物質的な体も光の速度で変化しているんです
ちょっと場所を変えただけでも体も変わってるんですよ
前の自分じゃないんです
時間ちょっと変わっちゃうと前の自分じゃないんです
この物質の変化も恐ろしいもんなんです
だからそんなことは知らんということだから
もう俺がいるんじゃないか
生まれた時からという態度でいます
しかし 本当のことを知っておくと
これはすごい不安も もう並大抵の不安じゃないんです
どうせ生きることは楽じゃないんです
大変なんです それで心の中でずっとこの不安ということがね
溜まっちゃうんですよ
それがなんとかごまかすんです
楽しいということは 友達がいっぱいいるんだと
携帯は絶対もう手から離せませんと
電車で降りようとしている瞬間ででもドアを開け
その時にまた始まるんですよ
携帯を そんなに忙しいかどうか分かりませんだけど
何やってるか私は知らないんだからどうでもいいんですけど
結局は送受信ことをやってます
携帯では物理的な送受信なんですけど
精神的には送受信なんです
ゲームやってることも同じなんです
なんかつまらなくなる
それでゲームやって楽しくなるんです
ゲームやるということも送受信の機能なんです
だからこの生きることっていうのは
放っておけば大変な ちょっと送受信やめてみれば
ものすごくイライラしますよ
そこで初めてお釈迦様がおっしゃったこの真理の第１
苦苦ということ わかるんです
やっぱり一切は苦であると
苦しみであると 生きることは苦しみであると
のんきになって執着するものではないんだとわかるんです
だからすごく嫌がるんですよ
瞑想は 瞑想でこの送受信機能はね
やめてもらうんだからね
そこでみんな病気になるわ
何もやってない すごく疲れたというし
何やったんでしょうかと
何もやってないのに疲れたとか血圧が上がったとか
もう言いたい放題嘘を言うんですね
それで私もああ そうですか
それは大変だと言わなくちゃいけないんだけど
言わないんです 完全に無視するんです
ですから この これ大変なことなんですよ
人間っていうのは送受信することで
ああ 楽しい 楽しいと で
あの生きることは苦であって
不安であるということはもう和らげてもらうんです
ごまかしですよ 電波塔がよく働く人は生きることが楽だと錯覚まで起こして自信満々なのです
大体人間っていうのはね
お釈迦様おかしいんじゃないかね
すべては空やと言ったことはね
そんなのはないでしょうと堂々と言うでしょうに
楽しいんだと よっぽど錯覚なんですね
だから我々にとっては送受信機能がものすごい働くんだったら
誰も修行しようと思わないんです
だって友達はいるわ 家族はもう仲良くしているわとかね
仕事はうまくいってるわとか
お金もあって 休みの時どこかに遊びにも行けるわとか
だったらこんなに楽しいなのに
何言うのかっていうことになるんです
これは何のこともなく
ただ単にその人の送受信機能がうまく働いているだけの話なんです
うまく送信する それは受信するバカもいる
それで自分もいろんなことを受信する
それまた自分にとっては気に入っている受信した情報は
それだけの話 それはどこまでやるのかと
ずっとそれできるのかということも気にしないんです
ずっと会社で仕事をできるのかと
若々しくて元気でいられるのかと
それは崩れますから その時は健康的な送受信機能が崩れますけど
その時ブッダは何言うんでしょうかと言ったって
もう手遅れですよ もう
だってかなり精神的な力がないと修行できんだから
大体仏教だけではなくて
人は宗教に興味 興味を持つのはもう社会で負けた時なんです
何か悩み 何か苦しみに引っかかった時に
一生悩み苦しみあるのに
それは気にしない ただ会社でクビになった
それが悩みだと 不正働かしでバレたと
それが悩みだ ではお寺に入って修行するぞと
で 期待はまた社会に戻ることなんです
そういう人々には本格的な修行はできません
ですから この  そんなもんで
送受信機能がうまくいっていると
みんなもう自信満々で
高慢で もう神も仏ももう馬鹿にしていて
うまくいかなかっちゃう
いかないと もうカエルでも犬でもキツネでも何でも拝むと
というのは まあ人間の普通の生き方です
そこでそう送信しないとストレスが溜まる
また受信できない時も
そこで自分がいろんなことを考えたりするでしょ
それは誰かに言いふらさないとストレス溜まるんです
だからみんな私のことを理解してくれとかね
認めてくれとか必死でしょうに
それから外からも情報入らないとイライラするんです
だから あらゆるものが体に刺激入るようにして生きているんです
でないと生きていられないほどストレスというものは溜まるんです
それも皆様言ってるストレスとは違います
これはお釈迦様がおっしゃっている苦なんです
同じなんですけど 我々は一部しかね
一生悩んで苦しんでいるのに
我々は会社でクビになったことだけ悩みというし
生きることは一生悩みなんですけど
子供が言うことを聞かない時
これだけは悩みですよというんだから
まあもう話になりませんだけど
だからストレスの場合も
ずっとストレスあるのに
ある これだけはストレスだと
ある一部だけハイライトするんです
はい なんています 入出力のレベルは同じではない
我々は同じ量を送信して同じ量を受信しているわけじゃないんです
なぜかというと 極端な 2つも教えますだからね
説明しましたから その時その時レベルが変わるんです
そこで波動の出出力が大きい人は
世の中の達人たちなのです
かなりド派手に送信 人々は世の中にいる
まあ成功者というか達人なんです
例えばビル・ゲイツの影響なしには誰にも生活できないんだから
そんなような感じなんです
アインシュタインのことを誰でも覚えているし
イエス様のことを知らない人はいないし
で だからまあすごい送信する
でも悟ってない人はそうやって世界のリーダーになっても
あのリーダーになる資格はないんですよ
ただ落ち着いてないだけ
例えば天才という人々というのは
ものすごい性格的にはものすごい混乱状態でしょ
時々もう精神的に病気になってしまう時もあります
一部ではすごい天才なんです
だから いろんなことを考えて考えてもいられない
だからそれで言って 言って
強引に他人に影響を与えたりする
それでリーダーにはなります
本人が自分ではもう耐えられないほどの不安定を送信することで和らげちゃうんです
しかし そういう人々はもうリーダーになるんです
だから彼らはリーダーシップを発揮するし
歴史に名前が残る だから歴史に名前が残っている人々は
みんなもうよっぽどの精神不安定さなんですよ
ナポレオンなんかはね
みんな随分ヒーロー扱いしてるでしょうね
けしからんな人間ですけど
全くもう落ち着かない
歴史に残っているみんなそうなんです
ちょっとまたもう一度考え直してみてください
そういう方々の性格は
アインシュタインにしても同じことなんです
もう考えずにいられない
あれこれとかね それで考えたことはもう発表する
それでも本人はもういろいろ相対論とかなんとかとかね
もう発見してからもうやめればいいでしょ
やめられないんです そこで自分が作った発見したものは違いますよというために必死でしたけど
うまく行けなかったんです
でも本人がもう自分がもう言った論理なんですけど
これちょっと違うと また別な考え方を作って
それは証明する以前に亡くなったし
いろいろなことを言ってはいたんですけど
あまりまとめることはできなかったんです
なぜかというと 他の人々はやっぱりあの相対論は正しいということをあちこちでも研究したり言ったりするんだから
だから面白いことは正しいんだったら
ああ そうか よかったということで終わればいいでしょうに
自分たち武装しているんです
やっぱり結局はかなりの慌て者なんですね
落ち着かないんです だから
そういうもうとてつもないことを考えずにいられないんです
だから そういう偉大なる方々はもう一方的に送信しているんです
送信して人類のリーダーになっちゃうんです
良い影響だけではなく
悪い影響を与える場合もこの方式です
それで歴史に名前が残っているのは良い人間だけじゃないでしょうに
極端な悪人の名前も残っているでしょ
だからまあ ものすごい犯罪を起こしたり
人を殺したりする人々も
ものすごい一方的にもう落ち着きがない
だから 例えばマフィアの出来事で映画どれぐらいできてますかね
それもすごい影響力なんです
リーダーなんですよ だから我々歴史を勉強すると
立派な人のことだけ勉強するわけじゃないんです
反対の人々のことも勉強したり
その人々もリーダーですよ
結局は 極悪人という人も人々のリーダーなんです
ビンラディンもリーダーなんですよ
あの人についていけば
もう人を殺さなくちゃいけない
自爆テロやらなくちゃいけない
じゃあ逃げましょうということはないでしょ
尊敬すると なぜかというと
あっちこっちでいろんなことをやっているんだからという話
事実はわかりませんだけど
受信は最大で 送信は最小の人々は社会にそれほど貢献しないのです
当たり前のことで まあ受信だけはする
何も送信しない人っていうのは
いてもいなくても全然まあわからない
我々と同じなんです いてもいなくても誰も知らんという
それは受信だけしているんだからなんです
それで自分の位置 送信力と受信力の差と質によって社会の中で個人の位置を定められるのです
まあ随分まあなんか数学の講義みたいなもんで
私は随分淡々と言ってますけど
で そこで我々はどれぐらい送信しているのか
どれぐらい受信しているのか
それは引き算でどちらプラスかマイナスか分かるでしょう
送信がプラスだったらかなり高い立場があるんですよ
送信が少ないんだったら
そんなに立場がないんです
存在感がないんです これは家庭の奥さんの例でよく分かりやすいかも
いろんな奥様方いるんですよ
かなり あの 何て言いますか
女帝みたいな感じで もうみんなを抑えている
旦那のお金なんですけども
自分が全部権力で全部管理
整理整頓している その場合は
その奥様はものすごい送信しているんです
悪いことした時点でものすごく怒る
旦那さんでもちょっとでも無駄遣いしたらものすごい怒る
で それでもう自分がもう送信たくさんたくさん送信しているんだから
その家族の人々もやっぱりこのお母さんがなければもう成り立たない
いつでも頼りにする もし突然亡くなっちゃうと
もう大変なことにショックを受けちゃうんです
それでまた別な奥様方もいますよ
随分身分が小さくて もう子供の奴隷みたいにいろんなやってあげて
子供に子供が怒っちゃうとすごい自分を引いちゃって
旦那が怒るとまた引いちゃって
誰か何かにちょっと寄付でもこれは旦那に聞かないと
いくら大事な用事があっても
ちゃんと ４時半で早くさっさと家に帰って
もう食事の支度をするとか
1 日でもサボっちゃうと大変だと追い出されるぐらい思っているんです
で その場合は受信するだけで何も送信しないんです
だから同じ家族の中で立場がない
みんなやりたい放題 そういうふうな具体的な例で考えてもわかりますよ
我々はたくさん受信するとじゃなくて
たくさん送信するといくらか立場がある
それで質も問題なんです
例えば悪いことばっかり
もう泥棒 強盗でもしましょうとかね
銀行強盗でもやりましょうとか
そういう悪いことを 強烈に受信する人は
まあその世界のアンダーグラウンド世界のリーダーになる
良いことを送信する人は良い社会の立派なリーダーにとか
自分の位置を決めるんです
だから皆様に一人一人に
この人間の社会でどこかで位置があるんです
自分がいる位置っていうのは考えてください
どこら辺にいるでしょうか
もう計算する方法を教えたんです
雰囲気を壊すという仕組み
それは照準の波長合わせの問題です
そこで雰囲気を壊しちゃったと
あの人は という場合ありますね
これは波長合わせの問題なんです
ある人が受信する構え構えでいる
送信者は違う波長の波動を送る
受信はするが 心が混乱状態になる
混乱状態になる 例えばですよ
悲しんでいる人が慰めを受信する準備したところで
相手が非難を送ると これ混乱するんですよ
例えば すごい悲しい出来事が起きちゃって
みんな様子を見に来る
それで悲しくなった人々は
やっぱりみんな慰めてくれると
という その受信する構えがあるんですよ
それで突然 一人がお前なんですか？とかね
あるいは別なこと なんであの日はこういうことをしたんですか？とかね
この間取った借金返せとかね
そんなもう場に合わないことを言っちゃうと
それ人も何か送信していますよ
送信するんだから 我々は受動モードで受信するんですよ
受信しても こちら合わせているチャンネルは慰めチャンネルだから
これがもう混乱するんです
まあテレビだってありがたいんですよ
合わせていないチャンネルは受信しないんですけど
でも日本のテレビではチャンネルの間がありますよ
もうさあさあさあっと隣のチャンネルの情報が受けちゃうんです
東京だったら例えば 7番目とかね
まあ 9番目とか といっ
まあでもあれは機械だからね
しっかり遮断することはできますけど
我々の場合は 例えば慰めチャンネルに合わせてるんですけど
もう非難のチャンネルの電波も受ける
だから相手が送信するものは受けるんですよ
それすごい危険といえば危険なんです
だからみんな常に動揺した心で生きているんです
だから心は動揺しないためには
このチャンネルのコントロールをね
常識にしないと これこれは受ける
これこれは受けませんとしっかりとチャンネル調整していないとね
しかし 人間っていうのは誰もチャンネル調整していないんです
バンドがすごい幅広いんです
だからもう何でも入るんですよ
何でも入るんだけど こちら構えているのは一つ一つのチャンネルなんです
これが合わないんですよ
それで雰囲気が壊しちゃったというんです
例えばね みんなもう酒飲んで
ものすごくワイワイと楽しくご飯食べながら楽しんでるところに私が行って
あのね 瞬間瞬間自分の行為に気をつけなくちゃいけないんだと
でないと心が乱れますよと言ったっても
どうなるんですかね もうこいつは雰囲気を壊したということになるでしょ
なぜかというと その場でみんな期待しているのは
もう焼酎が一番多い 焼酎で言ったって
もう北海道のあれがすごいですよとかね
それでもう一人 北海道じゃなくて沖縄
いろんなものを作ってますよとか
そういう話だったら雰囲気が盛り上がるでしょ
お互いに異論あっても盛り上がるんです
もう一人は まあ焼酎は悪くないんだけど
私はやっぱり西洋のブランデーやらウィスキーやらね
これはすごい好きですよとかね
飲めないとかね 日本酒なんかはと言うかもしれません
でもお前雰囲気壊すなよと誰も言わないんです
本当は異論違いですけど
雰囲気壊してないんです
例えば酒飲んでると 酒なんか飲むもんじゃないんでしょ？と言って酒飲んでも雰囲気は壊れないんですよ
なぜかというと これはもう
でもそれでも俺がやるぞという態度だから
だから送信する電波が合ってるんです
あるいはもう会社でいろんな苦しいことがなかったらね
こんなアル中になるまで酒飲まなくてもいいのにとかね
言いながらでも そんなこと言ってもみんなもう仲がいいと雰囲気は盛り上げていると言うんです
それで壊すということは全く波長が合わない時なんです
波長が合わない時も受信するんだからなんですよ
受信しなきゃいいんですよ
例えば こちらですごく楽しくワイワイとやっているところで
人がすっごく怒っていきなり部屋に入ってきて
キャーキャーキャーキャーいろんなことを言う
受信しなかったらいいでしょうね
しないならば受信しちゃうんですね
受信してその人出ていったら
みんなどっさりと落ち込んじゃうんです
受信しちゃったんです
こちら楽しい波長を受けようとしていたのに
もう嫌な波長が 波長の電波が入ったんです
受信しちゃったんだから
雰囲気は壊れてしまうんです
そこで雰囲気を盛り上げるということは
相手の受信機 心がその時合わせている波長に適した波動を送ることですよ
例えば 自分が雰囲気を盛り上げたければ
自分がこの人々はどんなチャネルに合わせてるのかと
ちょっと感じ それ簡単に感じますよ
雰囲気っていうのは それは一番簡単なことなんです
あの人何考えてるのか
そんなのわかるわけないんですよ
何考えてるのかわからないんだけど
どんな気分でいるのかっていうぐらいわかるんです
それをわからないと言うんだったら
もうやっぱりやめた方がいいんですよ
人間も だって医者もわかるんだから
医学的には何の説明もできないのに
この人はもうダメですよと
心臓止まってるのに頑張っちゃうでしょ
だからこの電波わかるんですよ
だから我々は雰囲気を盛り上げたければ
人を見ただけで もうこの方々はどんな波長に合わせてるのかとすぐわかりますよ
例えばもう人の悪口言ってるグループがいる
その時はだいたい嫌な気分
人は貶す 悪口 怒りとかね
憎しみとか嫉妬とかね
そういう波長でいるんですよ
そこで自分がその仲間に入る
入っても これ誰の悪口言ってるかさっぱりわからない
聞いてもその人は知ったこともないんです
でも人の悪口言ってるんだっていうぐらいは感じるでしょ
なんか嫌な気分でいるんだと
いきなりそういえばね
あのブッダさんはとんでもないやつやと
その人の悪口言ったっていいんだ
あれもなかなか悪人だよとかね
見事に雰囲気が盛り上がるんです
言ってる内容は全く違うんですよ
違うんだけど 波長を合わせているんです
それも人の悪口だから
そういうことで雰囲気を盛り上げるんです
例パーティーで隠し芸を広めるとかね
それで雰囲気が盛り上がるでしょうに
で パーティーというのは楽しむところで
隠し芸を広げることも
広げる 広める人も 私もなかなか捨てたもんじゃないかないでしょということで
自分の自己満足を表現しているんですよ
だからみんな楽しいんです
たとえ受信する側の機能が弱くても
明確に強力に受けたいと思っている波動を送り続ける人が
雰囲気を必ず盛り上げる
難しい文章になってましたけど
意味は簡単です 例えばこちらのグループはいるんですけど
全然聞く気持ちもないし
もう落ち込んでいるとかね
元気もなく そちらに強力な人が来て
ド派手にいろんなことを一方的に送る波動
そうするとまた雰囲気が盛り上がるんです
この例書いてますよ 例えば見える
読めるでしょうかね 披露宴に芸能人を招くことは一つの例なんです
例えば披露宴をやる いろんなところからいろんな人が来るんだから
お互いに仲良くするかがないか分からないでしょ
全然互いに知らない人も来る可能性あります
だって この人の親戚友達とこの人の親戚友達だから
それぞれのグループで知ってるかもしれませんだけど
合わせたらわからないでしょうね
それでみんなよくやる手段は
有名人一人 芸能人一人呼ぶんです
司会者として 彼がマイクロフォンを取った途端
みんなサーッとこちらそちら見ているでしょうね
その人も結婚式に合うか合わないか
どうったことなく もういろんなことを言うんです
でもかなり雰囲気は盛り上がるんです
大体芸能人やらこのもう何でしたっけ
この笑いやってる人々とかね
すごい強烈なんですよ
すごい一方的で だから人が疲れてこうやって落ち込んでいるんじゃなくて
ちょっと何か下を見ていたっても
そのやらせません 蹴ったり
いろんなことをしたり
いろんなことをやっても
とにかくもう盛り上がるようにする
だからまあ雰囲気は盛り上がるという
もう結構強引にやる場合もありますよ
だからまとめて言えば
まあ我々はそんな偉いすごい人間じゃないんだから
まあ自分の周りにいる人々はどんな波長に合わせているのかと見て
まあそれに合わせたことを言えばいいんです
単純ですよ 人間というのは欲か怒りか
憎しみか 嫉妬か 噂話か無駄話か
もうそんなもんでしょ
ふざけているか だからなんで合わせることできないと思いますかね
それぐらいだったら手の者でしょうに
だからもう簡単に雰囲気を盛り上げられます
はい 次 そこで様々な雰囲気で側変です
盛り上げてくれればそれで結構という
これで人々っていうのは
あなた雰囲気を盛り上げてくれればそれで結構っていうことで
出て行ってもいいやということになるんです
だから我々は一応盛り上げてくれるくれることしか期待してないんです
受信するだけなんですね
はい そういうわけで 私も人を盛り上げればそれで十分やと
それ以上期待するなよということを言いたいんです
これ側変だから仏教の話じゃないんです
たくさんあります 暗い雰囲気
明るい雰囲気という 2つは 2つしかありません
雰囲気で言ったら大きく分けて暗いか明るいか 2つしかない
自分が期待している波長に合わせてもらえば満足する
だから私は暗い雰囲気を受け受信したい時は
相手も暗いことを言って言ってくれればありがたいんですよ
結構盛り上がります そうなんですよ
もう実はとかね 例えば自殺したいと思っている人がいる
ものすごい暗い雰囲気でしょうね
その人と仲良くするよ
自殺なんかなんだ もう一緒にいてご飯食べよう
楽しみに行ったら合わないんですよ
話してくれない そうなんですよ
嫌な世の中 もう嫌で嫌で
家にいたっても嫌でしょうし
外に出たっても嫌でもうもう腹が立つわとか言っちゃうと合うでしょ
盛り上がるんです だからそれで満足するんです
披露宴は楽しくて 両親に感謝するときは泣かせてくれるなら最高という程度のものです
まあ披露宴に行った もう社会に行った人が
ものすごい雰囲気をものすごく楽しませて
みんな笑わせて そこでなんか文章を読み上げたりして両親に感謝するという
もうもうデタラメやってるでしょ
で その時はもう客をみんな泣かせてもらわないと
そんな決まりきってるものなんです
感動の場面とかね だから
この決まりきってる場合は波長がすぐ読み取れる
それに合わせればいいんです
何か目に何か入れてでもちょっと涙見せちゃうと
司会者でも誰でもものすごい雰囲気が盛り上がるんですよ
社会っていうのはそういう単純なもんなんです
だから好きできます そこで雰囲気という波長を分類してみると 5つです
1 泣くか悲しむということ
我々の波長はね 泣き 泣きたい気分でいるか
悲しみたい あるいは笑うか楽しむか
もう同じものですけど
3番目 欲に酔うか 怒りに狂うか
5番目だらけているかと
どんな人でもその 5つに入りますよ
そこで 1本でいるわけじゃないんです
その 5つの中で回転してるんで
どんな難しくないんですよ
だから皆様 雰囲気を盛り上げたければ
この 5つを覚えて この人 1 ですか
2 ですか  3 ですかと というと
3 であるとわかっちゃうでしょ
例えば欲に酔っていると
その場合はいっぱい欲の話すればいいんです
やっぱり儲ければいいねとか
株が当たった方がありがたいねとかね
なんとか欲の話をすればいいんですよ
泣きたい気分でいる人には
そういうなんとか言えばね
本人はただもう振られて悲しい気分でいるかもしれませんよ
でも自分には別に悲しいことは何もないんだけど
この間の台風で人が死んだことでもいいんですよ
うまく話をすれば やっぱり人間というのはいろいろ大変でしょうとかね
だってこの間見てください
ちょっと台風が来たことでもう何人 60人も死にましたよと
やっぱり悲しいことを言ってたらもう乗ってきます
向こうは失恋で振られて悲しがって泣きたい気分でいるんですけど
だから波長を合わせればいいっていうことなんです
だらけてるところに行ったら同じこと言っちゃえば
結構雰囲気が盛り上がります
その場その場受信する波長が決まっているから
それに合わせるだけでうまくいく
はい 次  ５つ覚えておいてください
で 様々な続編の 3番目のスライド
貪瞋痴の感情が雰囲気を作る
これは前も言いましたからね
感情っていうのは 仏教では貪瞋痴という ３つに分ける
あの 5つも貪瞋痴なんです ５
つにしたんですけど 場によって以上の 3つの中で一つだけアクティブになる
あるいは機能している
私たちとは貪瞋痴という 3本立てでいるわけじゃないんです
あのむさぼりにログインするか
怒りにログインするか
無知にログインするかと一つにログインするんです
機能するんです だから欲がある時は怒りは機能しないし
怒りが機能すると欲が機能しないということで
雰囲気を盛り上げる人はそれに送信を合わせる
だから怒りが出てきて
それでわかりにくいと思いますけど
怒りっていうのは落ち込みも怒り
嫉妬も怒りに入る 憎しみも怒りに入る
気分が悪いということも怒りに入る
機嫌が悪いっていうことも
ただ単に暗いっていうことは怒りなんです
だからかなり幅広いんだから簡単ですよ
ただ単に暗い人にでもすっごい怒りのことを言うと
ものすごく乗るんですよ
怒りに関わる情報を与えると
それで欲にしたっても
結構幅が広いんです えーと
皆の心は同じ感情でない場合は難しい
これ難しいんで 例えば 20人いるんですけど
一人が落ち込んでいて
一人が舞い上がっていて
一人がふざけてだらけていてとか
その場合は難しいんですよ
波長を合わせるのは だってこちらに送信できるのも一つの電波だから
この場合は結構難しい
この場合の取る手段というのは一方的にやることなんです
だからタレントさんなんかが来たら
人がもうもう舞い上がっていても
落ち込んでいても 混乱状態でいても
だらけていたっても 何のことなく一方的に喋って自分の雰囲気を与えて帰っちゃうんです
例えば葬式に行く人 皆悲しいとは限らないでしょ
それで葬式に行って もう悲しみに関わることばっかりやるとかね
悲しいですね 立派な人ですから
なんでいい人が早く亡くなるんでしょうかとかね
そういう話をすると結構雰囲気は盛り上がりますけど
葬式に来てる人はみんな亡くなった人のことを別に悲しんでいるわけじゃないんです
その時はちょっとずれることの可能性もあります
だから雰囲気を盛り上げることをできたとしても
いつでもうまくいくということじゃないんです
そんなもんで簡単ですから
次に行きます 雰囲気を盛り上げるワンちゃんの哲学
ワンちゃんに習っちゃえばね
なんで犬ってそんなに可愛いんですかね
犬は必死になって飼い主に合わせるんだからでしょ
だから犬に負けた人生ですけど
しょうがないんですよ
だから犬がいつでもこちらが波長が変わるたびにぴったし合う波動を出してくれるんです
それって犬に対しては大変なんですよ
犬がじーっと人を観察しているんです
しかし 人間っていうのは嘘つきだから
犬はそれを知ってるんです
だから顔をじーっと見たりはしないんです
例えば人がお茶飲んでるでしょ
飼い犬がそばにいる で
この自分の方を見ないでお茶飲んでる時
ちらっと見るんです その時読むんです
ものすごい上手なんです
だから飼い主は全然知らない
だからなんでいいのですか？ということを全部わかるんだと
すごい頭がいいんだというんです
自分がもう完璧に読まれているということは知らないんで
読まれているのは自分の方であると
それを覚えておいてください
そうするとうまくいきます
皆に多数派に従うことという要求に応じる
犬の哲学ってそんなもんですよ
でも我々はもう一対一の関係じゃないんだから
人間の場合はね 我々はたくさん人間と付き合わなくちゃいけないんですね
だから できるだけ皆に会う合わればいいんだけど
できなかったら多数派に
多数派の波長に合わせればいいんです
戦争するとき 怒り 憎しみ
勇気 勇気っていうのは
単なる相手を殺す残酷さにつける
装飾語です 勇気を持って戦えとかね
人殺しっていうことなんですけど
例えば戦争がある時はそういう話をすると雰囲気が盛り上がるでしょ
残酷な敵であると もう敵がご飯食べても
あの連中はご飯まで食べててとんでもないぞ
何でもいいんですよ もうとにかく怒りを出せば
非常に火に油をかける
それで雰囲気が盛り上がるということになるんです
戦争しようとしているところでね
やっぱりそんな人殺しは良くないんだと
落ち着きましょうと言っちゃうと
もう追い出されます 非国民になっちゃうんです
そこで 家族 会社 仲間との集まりなどで欲を引き上げる
それで雰囲気が盛り上がります
で なぜかというと 家族っていうのは
まあ欲に欲で固めているシステムなんです
会社も欲で固めているシステムなんです
仲間も同じなんです だから
欲を引き上げればいいんですよ
簡単です しかし 欲っていうのは一色ではありません
会社は儲かりたい 儲かりたいだけの欲でしょうし
あるいはライバル会社を潰したいということもあるかもしれませんだけど
これは自分に対してもたくさん儲かりたいことで
家族になってくるとまた違うでしょうに
で 例えば笑いも冗談も我が子が可愛いことも欲の一部なんです
だから我が子は可愛いということも欲なんですけど
金儲かりたいという欲とは随分違うでしょ
あの女の人はすっごい可愛い
セクシーだよという時の欲と
私の犬もすごい可愛いんだよという欲っていうのは随分違うでしょ
ものすごい違う 違うんだけど
欲なんです 全部 だからそのその欲に合わせて
まあ子供を子供と一緒にいる時はすごく可愛い可愛いとかね
ああ 上手上手とかね もう何やったっても褒めたりしちゃうと
もう子供はもう気分がいいんです
で 奥さんの場合はそれなりにそちらの欲をね
あんた疲れても化粧しなくても結構もうなかなか綺麗ですよとかね
一言言えれば  それだけのことで人生はうまくいくんですよ
今はやっているおしゃれな服一つも買ってないのに
君は結構セクシーですねとかね
すると奥さんがもう何言うんですか？という怒りますけど
あれは嘘です すっごく喜んでるんです
そういう風に それぞれの人が持っている欲を引き上げれば
会社も家族もどこでも盛り上がるんです
はい 次 年齢 性別 好き嫌いなどが一致しない時は盛り上げるのは大変です
それはみんな一緒になった時なんですよ
例えばこちら子供だけだったら
私は結構話の内容を変えますけど
同じこと言えますよ で
年齢が変わっちゃうとなかなか難しいんです
落ち込み的で 受信したいが
何を受信すれば良いかとわからない人々の場合も
波長に合わせて送信するのは難しい
時々もう何考えてるのか
どんな気分でいるのかとさっぱりわからない時もありますよ
相手があれは落ち込んでるんですね
だから何も送信してないんですよ
受信したいと思ってるんですが
本人もわからない どんな波長を受信すればいいかと
だから雰囲気が盛り上がりたい人は何喋ればいいかわからなくなっちゃうんです
その場合ももう何でもいいんだから
向こうはもうただ受信型だけだから
大体欲の方が簡単ですから
なんかもう欲に関わる話をすればね
盛り上がりますけど 難しいんです
周りが興奮状態で混乱状態でいる場合は
盛り上げない方がふさわしい
例えば自分が入ったところ
みんなものすごい興奮状態でいる
すごい混乱状態にいるんだったら
雰囲気は盛り上げない方がいいんですよ
何されるかわからないんです
なぜかというと 受信する気はありません
例えば興奮状態っていうのは
もうもう中ですごい混乱が起きちゃって
発信しているんです でも
発信に適して情報を受信したいという気持ちがないんで
その時はちょっと病気的な状態なんです
だから興奮しているところにいて
何か言ったら もうとんでもないことになるんです
じゃあみんな仲良くやりましょうとかね
歌でも歌いましょうで言っちゃうともうとんでもないことになるんです
その時は逃げた方がいいんです
その時は予測できないことをして状況を壊すと受信する
落ち着く 例えば人々は
例えば学校のクラスで
子供たちはものすごい興奮状態でキャーキャーキャーキャーとずーっと喋っていて
先生が入ってももう見ようともしない
では出席取るぞと言っても聞いてもないんです
だから一人一人にちゃんと座りなさいと言っちゃうと
先生に対してすごく怒るんです
出て行けと言う可能性もあります
その場合は なんとかその子供たちに予測できないことをすればいいんです
何でもいいんで いきなりステレオを持ってきて
ボーンと音楽を流すとか
いきなりびっくりするんです
それで落ち着くんです
では出席取るぞと言えばいいんです
それで受信する気にさせます
かなり音が出る爆竹でもいいんです
やっちゃえばびっくりし
予測できるんでしょうね
そういう人間の心っていうのはあまりにも単純簡単です
では次に行きます 上手になる裏技
裏技も教えてあげないと
自分こそが正しいという人の気持ちに訴える方法です
もし雰囲気を盛り上げることを上手になりたければ
人間にはすごい弱みがあるんです
その弱みっていうのは
自分が正しいという気分なんです
これではどんな餌も食っちゃうんです
釣られちゃいます 簡単にそれを使えばいいんです
怒ってる人も 憎しみを抱いている人も
欲に溺れてる人も 丸々異常の人も
殺し屋も政治家も 自分が正しいと思っている
だから政治家さえも自分が正しいと思ってるんだから
人殺しはね どうせ思うでしょ
自分が正しいと だから人っていうのは
例えばすっごい憎しんでる人がいる
相手を憎しんでいる あんた
なんで人を憎しむのかと
言ってはあきません いけませんよ
本人が相手があれやってこれやってこういうことをしたんだから
もう憎しみしかないんだと思ってるんです
自分が正しいと ということで
世の中であなたが悪いというふうに人を侮辱することをやめた方がいいんです
それを認める波動しか受け入れられない
それで人の気持ちっていうのは
自分が正しいという方向の波動なら
気持ち気持ちよく受け入れるんです
はい 次続けていきます
浦和さんのいかなる場合でも相手を批判することをやめる
例えば 人は人を殺して殺そうとしている時でも
もうなんてことをするのかではなくて
まあまあまあもうちょっとまあいいんじゃないか
それぐらいでとかね なんとかその相手を否定しないで言うと
まあ放っておいて まあこんな虫を殺したってもね
シャレにならんだからとか言っちゃうと
ああそうかということでやめるんですよ
そういう風に変えることしかできないんです
代わりに認める 褒める
おだてる 評価するという手段を選ぶんです
普通の人間は 何て言いますか
褒めてくれる 認めてくれるなら何でもしたくなる乗りやすいものです
人間っていうのはもうちょっとうだてればもう何でもする
どこでも飲む だからそんなもんですよ
人間っていうのは見たい
見て認めたくはないが事実です
これ認めたく 自分に対しては認めたくないでしょ
でもそれ事実なんです
乗りやすいっていうことは
私はそうじゃないんだよと言いたいでしょうね
まあでも事実ですから
もう気をつけた方がいいんですよ
もう簡単に褒めてくれただけでもう
結構雰囲気が盛り上がります
はい まあそれであの仏教のところに入りますが
ちょっと疲れたので 10 分ぐらい休憩いたします
ありがとうございます